this is a P90 it's a compact lightweight
with a cyclical rate of fire of 900
rounds per minute
from its shape and operation as well as
its place in our pop culture the fnp90
is one of the most unique SMGs both in
reality and as a popular pick for the
Weaponry of many first-person shooters
so we've come here to the Royal armories
and leads joined by keeper of arms and
artillery Jonathan Ferguson to take a
deep dive into this very 90s PDW as well
as break down what it brings to the
world of Pop Culture be that in the
hands of bond or as a team of five Rush
objectives with a P90 a piece
foreign
[Music]
Ty is another essential entry into a
modern virtual Arsenal now I think but
can you give us a brief history of it in
reality so this is another weapon that
originates from a specific military
requirement requirement this time it's
NATO as an overarching military
organization and something that some
viewers will be familiar with the
personal defense weapon or PDW now
although this and the HK MP7 are what
emerge from that effort by PDW NATO
didn't mean a space submachine gun which
is what those two weapons effectively
are at least to us in video gaming world
that just meant literally any weapon
that a military person might carry to
defend themselves with so P90 project 90
coming from FN her style who one of the
biggest arms companies in the world not
just the scar but but this so compact
light portable but also the ability to
penetrate soft body armor and that
resulted in epistle class round if you
can if that makes sense and the five
seven very small diameter relatively
long very high velocity and there's a
few things about it the round being one
that isn't represented in too many games
escape from tarkov has some details
about
um P90 rounds and five seven rounds
being better armor penetration but I
think the main thing that's the draw
into video games is that it's another
weapon that because of its statistics
broadens the class of SMGs or pdws in
video games not only is it aesthetically
very interesting but the 50 round
magazine immediate gameplay benefit but
also the the operation and the the
magazine itself's very interesting adds
more um aesthetic differences so can you
sort of walk us very briefly through
that magazine I think that's probably
one of the most iconic elements of this
weapon yeah I mean you can regard that
as the heart of the system really you
know it literally sits in the middle of
the of the design uh the magazine
dictates where you know where you're
feeding from and basically where
everything else goes and in this super
compact design I mean it's just so short
[Applause]
superbly compact I mean it's not pistol
compact the MP7 you can you can make
shorter but yeah still it's a it's a
brick but but a very slim brick
so we have our
pullback lift and pull out now the
magazines are a little bit awkward you
do need a specialized load carrying
solution to actually carry these because
that's the drawback 50 rounds means it's
very long and a quirky reload as well
and the rounds are coming in sideways as
we all know from the various different
attempts to animate that and then
they're rotated by the follower
and they are inserted in front of the
bridge or into the breach rather
foreign
it's interesting because the the
magazine is so iconic but games have
been very limited to how they can
actually animate because that's the bit
players are going to see they're seeing
the weapon from this angle but a lot of
games aren't able to especially
especially when it first start appearing
it was just like a brick but even modern
games now sort of hide it like Rainbow
Six Siege they've just put tape over it
I noticed that yeah that was weird yeah
but it's one of the most iconic things I
think it's always really nice when it's
such an interesting weapon that that
element specifically is represented and
you can see the the rounds being fed and
I feel like a lot of the the weapons
that are coming out around a similar
time lent into this sort of Bassy blocky
look I I do wonder if that if if the
look of this made it more or less
difficult to to sort of build and design
in video games like one of its first
appearances was in 007 GoldenEye on the
n64. absolutely obviously not animating
the the magazine and the reload is I'm
back but nonetheless it's
it's one of the weapons that even at its
virtual infancy because of its
Aesthetics and its shape is completely
recognizable but as I was looking
through its life in bond I think this I
mean it looks like a
sort of spy weapon anyway but owes quite
a lot to bond its first appearance of
video game has been GoldenEye despite it
not appearing in the movie but then in
the world there's not enough in that
scene when they're fighting in the
nuclear bunker that's one of its very
earliest appearances actually in action
being fired being like in the hands of
both the hero and the villain that the
peanut is I think you know that's that's
one of the elements that immediately
catapulted it into Fame it was cemented
into Bond very early both in its biggest
video game not his best movie but
in a Bond movie that's got that's gotta
account for something since then it's
been I think a Mainstay in both video
games TV pop culture throughout
so with the with the Sci-Fi Aesthetics
that's
been sort of tweaked a lot in games this
sort of
Magazine change
here I think has been replicated in so
many virtual Firearms now just just the
fact that if a gun has this top loading
magazine it's it's got P9 DNA in it I
think that's unavoidable like Black Ops
2 had a guns very similar to this the
PDW 57 and infinite Warfare had the fhr
40 and sometimes they'll do things like
it swivel out or anything like that but
if you're making a Space Gun and it's
got this
it's you know it's it it's a distant
cousin to the P90 right but in in
reality
we've not really got anything that's
close to a version two of this or or the
next iteration of the P90
doesn't really exist yet right no and
you know having that very Niche origin
uh all all driven around that little
short Stumpy pseudo rifle
style cartridge you know it's like a
scaled down rifle cartridge and the way
FN went with this being being super
compact you've got this you can compare
this grip to the fg42 first patent fg42
where the similar ID you want to keep it
as short as possible the only so many
places you can go with it it's
distinctive you know it's not it's also
not super modular you know it's a
Bullpup already so you can't really do
anything with the stock the only thing
you could do with the ergonomics would
be make it to make it more conventional
to put a pistol grip and a stock on this
is a retrograde step in terms of what FN
we're trying to accomplish
so you're not this isn't this is going
to remain in the P90 you might see a bit
more modularity up front they've already
you know you already had provision for
we've got a rail here the Tri-Rail
receiver there are aftermarket versions
of that they're a little bit slicker
than the FN version
no one has has managed to reinvent the
P90 I don't think
I don't think any of this might be even
show my age at this point but I don't
think you can mention the p9e without
talking about Stargate sg1 of course not
well I didn't realize let's say first of
all
it's a perfect gun for that Universe the
near future trying to tie in sci-fi and
reality looking a bit like a space gun
suited perfectly even though this is in
my mind the most very very tied to that
property it wasn't until the fourth
season like late in the fourth season as
well that it first appeared and it's one
of the few examples where like the Hero
characters actually have a line about
why they've swapped weapons because it
was originally the MP5 in that show
there's a few few scenes in that in that
show where they really like shine a
light on the P90 this weapon is called a
P90 it carries a 50 round top loading
magazine of Teflon coated Ordnance with
a cyclical rate of fire of 900 rounds
per minute
one thing that I found well while
looking into this was that it was I
think one of the stunt coordinators
really wanted it because due to its you
know as was the ejecting below it made
it all that easier to get good shots of
the heroes shooting because they weren't
having to worry about brass flying over
their face or the camera being over
their brass flying that way
so that was one of the reasons why the
peanut appeared in that show and also
because the show was banging and really
popular no I absolutely loved the the
sg1 depiction I I remember it first time
around because I'm old it was great
because the MP5 was was the default
Special Operations Close Quarter battle
type weapon at that time still early
2000s they were depicted somewhat
realistically in their kit they were a
small self-sufficient Special Operations
unit going off to do their missions so
the MP5 fit nicely with a few
accessories on it and then to Pivot to
this even in Universe it made sense you
know even smaller sort of form factor
the armor penetration thing I remember
the line about how this is going to
penetrate this alien body armor these
guys are wearing you know the the pistol
bullets aren't doing the job as a as a
nerd and a gun nerd even then I I really
appreciated that and you know they keep
something small and com and compact like
that but with a high high Firepower
without before you have to change
magazines what could be better to break
contact with um some you know scary
aliens and get back through your
Stargate than that so it made a lot of
sense in terms of sci-fi fun but also in
terms of If This Were Real what weapon
would you want I think that would be a
great candidate on paper anyway and I
think that you know elements you
mentioned make it so that the P90s
Legacy in games is never going to go
anywhere it's not being replaced in real
life can't see it ever being replaced in
fiction there's guns that apis
Aesthetics and its use but there's just
nothing that I think can can beat the
P90 whether you're doing something
sci-fi or where
you're rushing a site with four of your
mates screaming profanities and trying
to clutch out CS go around it's a niche
weapon it'll always be a niche weapon
but it's surprisingly popular if you
look up lists of users of these things
yeah it's not a standard military weapon
it's not even a standard police weapon
but all sorts of Special Operations
especially Security Forces yeah it's the
most successful modern submachine gun I
would say
um obviously the MP5 is probably still
the most successful but in terms of the
next generation of submachine gun I was
going to say the only thing to consider
is
despite its video game depiction this is
probably one of the most difficult
weapons to dual wield but that's
something we'll cover in the akimbo
episode
[Music]
[Music]